j'en viiens maintenant aux César qui ont
occupé une bonne partie de la soirée
d'hier du moins si vous regardez Antenne
2 mais même si vous regardez Antenne 2
vous n'avez pas plus voir le l'uréa
principal celui qui a obtenu le Prix
d'interprétation masculine c'est-à-dire
Philippe Léotard et Philippe Léotard
nous venons de réussir à le débusquer il
était au Théâtre des Amandiers à à
Nanterre en train de répéter en train de
jouer une pièce euh on est donc ravi de
vous découvrir si vous aviez su que vous
étiez le lauréa vous seriez venu au Rex
vous auriez abandonné votre théâre des
amandi je vis préciser une chose
quelqu'un vient de me dire que on avait
dit an 2 excusez-moi je joue au théâtre
j'ai la voix un peu cassée que je sais
pas j'avis pas pu venir pas voulu joue
au théâtre et c'est une pièce qui
commence à être joué donc il arrive qui
arrive depuis une semaine puisque c
pièce pas qu'on répète beaucoup on joue
beaucoup joue tous les soirs le
spectacle d'abord de toute façon ça
finiss à 11h moi je finis à
11h30 alors matériellement impossible
très franchement est-ce que on sait pas
à l'avance quand même qu'on est lauréa
ça dépend sur les antennes ou pas bon il
y a desjens des bruits non oui c'est ça
non des bruits non pas des bruits
transpirants mais des bruits de face des
gens qui vous disent j'ai voter pour toi
au 100e on se dit combien qui vote alors
ou j'ai que des potes
menteurs al c'est moi parce que c'était
une surprise he on attendait de par pas
moi du tout j'étais sûr que c'est pas
moi mais j'étais prêt à ce que ce soit
moi on est quatre c'est pas difficile de
partager en quatre éventuelle
responsabilité qu et si vous l'aviez su
si vous aviez été libre ce soirl vous
seriez venu vous bien sûr je suis venu
j'ai oui j'ai perdu non non mais je veux
dire je suis sorti du théâtre et je suis
venu directement à l'endroit où était
mes camarades tout le monde mais bien
sûr que je Seris venu avant pu c'est un
rit auquel vous aimez participer vous P
j'adore ça les décorations les
cérémonies et c'est une fête importante
pour le
cinéma j'espère que j' l'ai encore pour
moi oui oui oui je pense c'est important
excusez-moi je suis un petit peu excité
parce que je sors de scène qu'est-ce que
ça peut vous aider à conquérir que vous
l'ayez
déjà euh je sais pas je sais pas je sais
pas
j'espère mieux travailler j'espère
pouvoir continuer à
faire un film qu'on aime une pièce de
théâtre qu'on aime pouvoir être un peu
plus libre
quoi je sais pas je vois pas d'autres
choses vousz en face de vous deux deux
deux espoirs parce que il y a le
meilleur espoir Sophie Marceau et puis à
ses côtés le meilleur second rôle Fanny
cotanon le meilleur ancien espoir vous
aviez donc vous êtes maintenant le
vétéran consacré définitivement bonjour
les filles vous vous aviez voté pour
l'une et
l'autre pas la vérité non mais c'est un
votre secret alors si on le dit après ça
viient quoi on peut bien dire oh j'ai
pas envie non non j'ai pas envie parce
que la réponse est forcément piégé si je
dis non c'est pas gentil pour mes
camarades c'est gentil pour d'autres
remarquer
si dis oui ils V direou tu dis oui parce
que tu es alors puisque vous êtes
l'ancien là maintenant le consacré
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez le donner
comme conseil
des la
passion je peux pas
done d'être heureux quoi c'est ça le vra
bonheur je sais pas je sais pas quoi
dire
de d'avoir envie et puis de prendre de
prendre que la vie leur laisse ce
qu'elle leur prendo de servir qu'il a je
sais pas ce qu'il y a dans leur vie si
on s'en sert pas c'est fout
jeoton à votre tour peut-être de donner
un conseil à Sophie Marceau qui a
quelques années de moins que vous dans
le cinéma oh c'est à peu près les mêmes
choses qu'
[Musique]
pH avoir le plaisir de jouer ça me fait
très peur d'entendre philiip parce que
je vais jouer au théâtre et j'aimerais
pas ça
m'arriverive la voix cassée mais
ouioir vraiment le plaisir avoir tout le
temps l'envie l'envie l'envie de jouer
le plaisir et et et exister vivre vivre
je crois que c'est c'est en fait ce
métier c'est c'est c'est ni plus ni
moins fa que d'exister comme ça à
travers les rôles qu'on joue vous savez
que natthalie ba non nonvez que Natalie
B qui a eu comme vous plusieurs fois
deux fois déjà le prix du deuxè meilleur
rôle a eu donc hier enfin le prix
d'interprétation féminine c'est votre
rêve un jour ah bah oui sauf Philippe
Noiret m'a dit avant le avant il m'a dit
peut-être que peut-être que tu auras le
le prix prix le César mais tu en auras
deux d'un coup le premier et le dernier
et c'est ce que je pense
vraiment je pense pas que ça il y aura
de suite c'est terrible ça c'est
terrible quand on l'écoute bien et
Philippe ltin la connaît
bien Nathalie Ba a l'air vraiment
d'avoir les pieds sur terre son succès
elle l'a pris pas très goulument mais
doucement et elle trouve que c'est
finalement une suite logique mais mais
mais elle ne prend pas ça comme une un
coup de foule dans dans dans dans sa vie
est-ce que c'est votre s exactement
c'est exactement pareil j'étais très
c'est ce que j'ai dit à la télévision
j'étais très très très contente deavir
ce cés ça sur le coup ça m'a donné une
énergie folle j'ai pensé à mes parents
j'ai pensé à à mes amis comédiens qui
répète en fait qui je répète en ce
moment j'ai ça m'a donné une force comme
ça mais c'est une force passagère après
mon se retrouve devant le travail et et
retrouver ce plaisir qu'on a eu enant ce
film ENF étoile du Nord le plaisir que
j'ai eu avec Simon signor en plus avec
Simon avec Philippe Philippe leotard
justement quand on vous a dit sur scène
hier soir entre deux répliques que
c'était Nathalie Ba qui avait le le
César ah non on pas dit ça on c'est moi
et puis après on a dû dire en scène j'ai
trouvé la plaisanerie un petit peu
dépassé parce que j'étais sûr que non
j'étais sûr que j'étais prêt mais je
savais bien que c'était pas moi le
machiniste m'a dit ça quand j'is rentré
je dis écoute c'est
je suis pas très prêt à à trouver drôle
à ce momentl pu en sortant il y en a un
deuxème d'ord puis ça m' fait coup ça je
sais pas moi je suis très sensible
à il y a bien quelqu'un qui vous a dit
que il y avait aussi quelqu'un qui avait
eu le prix d'interprétation féminine
c'est oui c'est ça oui bien sûr mais ça
je m attendais davantage et alors
j'étais content oui ça m' fait
plaisir ie depuis un moment et ça m'a
fait plaisir que ouais bien sûr c'est
important pour elle puis je suis sûr que
ça va l'aider àid a pas besoin d'être
aidé mais ça lui permettre encore mieux
par c'est une fille qui a toujours
progressé depuis début alors c'est
vraiment bien je trouve j'étais content
de C César un peu collectivement puis
quand je suis arrivé
euh au
fouquess et tout le monde av content de
me voir alors ça fait du bien ça c'est
pas tellement d'avoir le César c'est que
les gens vous disent qu'il vous aiment
alors on leur demande pas grand chose de
plus he finalement Sophie Marceau on
vous a pas entendu pour l'instant je
vous pas poser de question à qui vous
avez envie de ressembler parmi toutes
ces actrices dont on parle les grandes
les Américaines les Françaises c'est sûr
qu'on a qu'on a toujours des idoles en
tête mais je pense que le principal
c'est de faire d'abord un travail propre
à sa propre personnalité
et j'ai envie de devenir ce que
je j'ai envie de devenir ce que je
seraiis suivant mon travail je dire vous
avz pas une idole genre Gat Garbo ou je
sais qui en France si on a on a toujours
des idoles comme katrineb par exemple
mais si je continue dans le cinéma
j'espère je croise les Loig je suivrai
peut-être une carrière complètement
différente et chez les Françaises
actuellement laaffiche il y a pas de
référence si j'aime beaucoup not animal
bien sûr et enfin plein d'autres je dire
je crois que moi j'aime tous les gens
qui qui qui font ce métier avec amour et
à partir du moment où ils le font avec
amour je pense que ce sont des bons
comédiens et c'est ça le principal alors
pour vous fortifier il va peut-être
falloir faire ce que fait en ce moment
fan coton c'est se mettre au théâtre ça
va vous arriver c'est mon rêve de faire
des théâtre ouais pourquoi pas peut-être
dans quelqu temps mais je crois que
c'est une très bonne école pour le
cinéma en plus et même au risque d'avoir
la voie cassée je j'adorerai faire du th
et puis vous sortirez de la ligne boom
il y aura pas de Bo num non non non je
veux pas je vais essayer de m'étendre
sur autre chose d'accord bon ben merci à
tous trois on va écouter Philippe dum
qui va nous parler de la météo oui et
bien disons que pendant encore